Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. I have talked about my disdain for
kids menus.
Here is someone who misunderstood my comment
and isn't pleased with me.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 8: Hey, David Robert Asher from St.
Louis First-Time Caller.
Yes.
Want to talk to you a lot about various Trump
related things and my arguments on Facebook
with my friends.
But you were doing a thing about Applebee's,
and you talked about kids menus just being
what the adults did, but in smaller portions
as if that were a bad thing.
But isn't that what the kids menu is supposed
to be?
Speaker 1: Yes, this so you misunderstood.
My point was I am the he mentally against
what has become the de facto American kids
menu.
You go to a steakhouse or you go to a burger
bar or you go to a noodle shop or you go to
even some Asian or Indian restaurants.
And the kids menu is the same thing.
It's grilled cheese noodles with butter, chicken
fingers with fries, no matter where you go.
I'm against that.
What I mean by the kids menu is smaller portions
of what the adults eat is.
Kids should just be having smaller portions
of what the adults eat.
You know, these these stereotype, oh, kids
don't like fish, well, they don't like it
because a lot of Americans don't give kids
fish until they're seven, and by then, they've
not developed a taste for it all over the
world Thailand, Japan, Argentina, Spain.
Kids are having shellfish and fish all the
time, and that's what it is.
Oh, kids don't like spicy.
Well, in India and Pakistan and Thailand and
China, kids are having modestly spicy stuff
all the time.
So my my point is I like the idea that what
you don't really need a discreet kids menu
because it just the kids eat smaller portions
of what the adults are having.
That's not what is the kids menu in most places.
I'm against the grilled cheese pasta, chicken
fingers kids menu, please.
Let's understand what I am saying.
That's my point.
All right.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
The Mayo Clinic has fired 700 employees because
they are not vaccinated, 700 employees.
December job growth doubled.
The expected numbers doubled.
That sounds like a great economy.
Well, we're going to dig into the numbers
and think about it a little more deeply.
And a father and son plead guilty to Trump.
Riot charges.
It runs in the family, folks, and I'm sort
of joking when I say that, but it really does.
It really does.
So we will talk about all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show.
Tomorrow's live stream of the Trump press
conference is canceled because the press conference
is canceled.
We will have other live streams this week
and next.
Tuesday, January 11th, 6:00 p.m. Eastern.
We'll be doing a very casual chess tournament.
Players of all levels are welcome.
This is a great community thing.
Last time we did it, I think we had 500 or
600 players.
It was great.
Some grandmasters, international masters,
women's feeder masters are going to be participating
in the tournament.
I hope that you will participate.
It'll be January 11th at 6:00 p.m. Eastern.
Just make an account on Chess.com and then
I'll have information about how to sign up.
It's free.
I'm selling you nothing, folks.
It's completely free to play and I hope that
you will.
All right, we'll see you on the bonus show.
Sign up!
Get a membership at Join Pacman dot com, which
will give you instant access to the bonus.